friendly introduction to lambda calculus
and I'm not sure how friendly this
actually is so that's sort of strike
number one it also advertised me as a
homotopy theorist now you might wonder
what theory has got to do with the
lambda calculus if you want to know the
answer to that I'm not sure how long
this is gonna take and I know we
generally for a long talk soon I think
breaks so I guess when people get tired
issue and interrupt and I'll tell you
how much time I think I have left I know
there's enough stuff okay and then we're
gonna go back to you roaring eighteen
hundred's just say his name no Reagan
yes
this is Panter this is a virtual Russell
yes thank you logic
I probably didn't get your favorite
logician which i Frigga puts forth an
accusation of mathematics someone at the
time of course Russell disappoints Vega
in a in a handwritten letter to him when
he helped will be what we now know is
the Russell's paradox yeah
and cancer the pine nervously the
formulated which I can't pronounce
okay
spi system which I'll actually define
later in the talk the song formal system
for logic based in this notion of
communist-era function well you can do
is hide them to each other or form them
or form terms of Nesquik we also did
this roughly contemporaneous
independently to tackle this beast
called substitution which was sort of I
don't know a loose end
for instance in Russell and Whitehead
forgive me Annette matica and it
continues to sort of be whenever you
whenever you read on that medical logic
text since we describe substitution a
sort of
subscribe
Hey okay there go on to define for me
the language would this is a little
function that takes something as before
parentheses were invented Russell
Bertrand Russell is really smart
actually we all know parentheses in the
existence of listings very many
subjective mathematical object was
various ways
the sort of statements you can what you
can write down and how you can transform
what you just wrote down this is
something else
basically very specific about what you
can in come out to you and I know this
is all people are doing this in age
before you have before you had some
eilers and things to check whether or
not you did something correctly okay for
things to run these things on and
actually I was thinking about running a
lambda evaluator to make this talk but I
decided that well you know
Kirstin gonna have such a thing so I'm
just gonna do it all by hands except the
church also didn't have variables
near surrender particularly a lot of
kings of sugar because it's really
wonderful
okay here's the rules for lambda term
combination these rules explain what you
can write down so then I can apply it in
the language interesting sidenote
church
Church wasn't really so focused on all
the things we could write down in his
language having meaning in the same
sense so he was like you can believe
language you can make a host of
meaningless statements but also make
meaningful statements okay okay fine so
we can make all sorts of things have
intuitions behind them a function
abstractions will usually think that yes
yes Oh a little parent even all my
parentheses right
I know how thank you yes maybe video
maybe like plus or minus like
parentheses for the halls for writing
things down
yeah paper until I give you a friend
niculae ting them right perspective on
what meaning is
roof terrace like to write formal
systems down and then have rules for
emulating one to another model theorists
like to take the formal systems a napkin
to some
ie lambda it was recursive definition
okay
Adam look as the substitution problem
and it's really just function
application then rigorously to find it
once and for all a reduction okay there
you go
I guess I'm going down variable and
determined that necessarily a variable
hit me a variable doesn't really make
sense if it's just a variable function
okay so what I want to think of some
lambda term is a function every regime
inside another term
that's it firm key X appears notation
for substitution yes yes very so we run
into similar
I didn't see this anywhere they're right
pretty The Devil's of formation my
language at Salomon and then I'm going
to apply we're applying this wolf form
to 2z look whatever you ax I'm going to
put a G another parameter also
equivalents first so W like hand that
first should be different sorry
okay let me know when I can go back
actually these slides will be posted -
yes yeah excellent a beta reduction for
that put it in teen next sorry these
sort of those a free variable wasn't
done by anybody then we put in that
expression - somebody came bound okay
and then also you have to if X is bound
any sub expression you can't go ahead
and find the substitution
I think go forward okay
next production captures extension Oni
which is a fancy word for something
original
the two functions are essentially equal
and use the same thing that is they take
the same values to the same two
different kings so in a sense they're
different right I just two different
things
then we'll go to arithmetic schemes and
although it can show that the whole
theory
yeah yes Strasser is the confluence yeah
okay
okay that's enough math okay I don't
know if that's math but we can start
braiding programs and the first of all
can I introduce is this which we all do
is beginning programmers to the program
actually I guess I'm already making
identification between programs and
lambda terms which might be specious but
successfully written an infinite loop
which they're evaluated
okay wonderful
you like to intuitively you'd like to be
able to take the lantern just keep
backing it with reductions okay all
right so now we would like to do more
interesting things than that
Oh and I waited to find numbers Louise
and conditionals introversion and if
you're looking at
turns out to be
and so for any number you can make
another one for you it's gonna get worse
presidents gonna get much worse what
and then this way here so so we usually
use it next slide
all right or I guess you could say
there's two plus two more why is the
same
so let's see what I do here to this turn
is turn and put in this guy right here
first we're going to reduce this
this is like okay
and then I need to be on the project to
wear this according to the first or
second port so not an ominous sign
teacher anymore
and then to give no to the other because
deny
defining most apparent should be a T
Harrison T takes of t + 6 + s and
returns and value
condition sort of aconitine here sorry
yes
zero let me take the impose and positive
the function is
I
my commenters I could reach
well what if we supposed to medical tech
for real
reduces
- willing that little bit decide and we
get that form okay okay
yeah this is not the rigor that we show
that we show us two plus two more before
we sort of using not going to do four
three three there it is
but he reduces to fact the back in V we
do it again ready G it's almost reduces
the faculty back convene continue so we
had such a certified magic blue square
things
everything's a fixpoint there is a
lambda term
alright alright
Oh
No
we're taking the system
here on CMT's assertion assertion I
guess I guess it's done insurance which
applies whether strings there's no lemon
term that
there we go that's better
we can make comedy to those weird
correlation between these common errors
and interesting statements of the
propositional logic baby flies with me
imply state was an axiom
so if I have a proof of a I still have
it
if a 85 team my seat in pies and mighty
implies a my CEO joking about the test
time here so nobody somebody editorial
logic said this is great where again you
cannot you cannot define
if I have to wait at alternative group
survey into folks that be my see right
today I see
geez alright then give it a routine yes
actually
Hey
this is well
my hands